[Music]
hello my name is Gillian poor like oh
I'm a national master from the state of
Missouri and today I'd like to talk
about the a six law so actually this
this is probably going to be like a
three-part series I'm mostly going to
talk about complex of openings which
start from this structure with with D D
5 and C 6 playing on the light squares
so next week I'll probably talk about
the caro-kann with against e4 but right
now we'll stick to a defense against d4
and then the week after that I'll
probably talk about the London system
which starts with d4 and if your
opponent goes d5 then you play Bishop f4
getting your pawn alright your bishop
outside of the future pawn chain with e3
and then c3 and you have kind of the
same structure in all of these openings
but tonight we're gonna start looking at
the a6 love which happens after d4 d5
White's main reply here is c2 to c4 c6
so black wants to defend the d5 pawn but
he doesn't necessarily want to lose his
senator point one of his two Center
pawns in exchange for a side plan so if
you were to play e6 here then
potentially later like Knight c3 Knight
of six white could take on d5 and he has
exchanged a side pawn for a central pawn
which could be considered a good
exchange for the white player so that's
why c6 is is use sometimes played here
the the only downside to playing c6 over
e 6 because e 6 also blocks in the
bishop is that potentially you're taking
away a very good square from your knight
but at the same time we do reinforce the
central pawn on d5 so white usually
develops with Knight of three or nine c3
the move order here isn't so important
we're trying to get
a type of position so night at night of
three night of six and Knight c3 now
here to explain why black should play a
six or debatably shouldn't because there
are other most here we need to look at
the other rooms so I will ask the
audience what would you play here with
the black pieces a6 well that's a good
choice but anything other other than
that esis right so e6 the semi Slav now
the problem with in Pont X right so the
main lines are East six ASA a six and
the very main line of this opening is to
take on c4 with the plot now this is the
main line Slav and we'll discuss that in
a second but the reason why I don't want
to recommend a six it's because it does
temporarily block in this Bishop there
aren't solutions to this problem but
it's not within the scope of this video
and also if you want to check that out
Jonathan surance has fantastic series on
the semi Slav himself the main line what
black would really like to do right is
he'd like to move his Bishop from CA but
there's a problem if you move it to f5
or g4 then white will take on d5 and
then he'll play Queen b3 and because the
bishop is no longer on CA b7 is
extremely weak so this is a an attack on
b7 and on d5 and blacks best move here
is actually just serrated as bishop back
to ca which is in the very inspiring
mode if you have to go Bishop from CA to
f5 then then your next moves Bishop see
it probably you've done something wrong
you can try to do something else like
Queen d7 but then you're going to run
into problems with 95 so Glac would have
tactical issues so a6 is played as like
a waiting move but the mainline Slav is
d takes e4 and the point is that if
white tries to play e3 or e4 then he'll
hang on to his pawn with b5 if you play
a 4 then he'll get his pawn out of uh
sorry his Bishop out side of the pond
train
Chane but the problem with this position
for black from my perspective is that
I've exchanged my D pawn for the C pawn
because White's gonna eventually when
his pawn back with 95 in Knight c4 or e3
and Bishop c4 and we'll have a slight
plus due to his central majority it's
definitely possible through this move
order if your opponent Knight of three
to play push it about five after Knight
c3 that's not possible it should be
noted so if white plays Knight c3 here
instead of an eye of three which like
probably half the time your opponent's
will do because they transposes right
Knight c3 is played to avoid like the
note boom and other and other variations
what I yeah this this is also a thing
like a five but this is good for this is
good for white after a e5 takes Queen I
592 Queen e5 Knight f3 you move your
queen somewhere I think c7 g3 white is
slightly better Bishop f5 does not work
because I take on d5 and then play Queen
b3 and d5 and b7 is hit yeah so that's
why you can't really count on Bishop f5
being a move in these in this position
because from a repertoire point of view
right half the players are going to play
Knight c3 so in half the games you're
not going to be able to do that right so
I mean it is something like Bishop f5 is
a move that you can look at is like
maybe a surprise weapon but honestly I
think if you want to play this type of
position than a six of the better move
so knight Knight f6 Knight c3 and
finally we come to the move a six and
this is the main topic of discussion so
the reason why we play a six is now
potentially whenever Queen b3 is played
right after we move our Bishop we have
the option to play b7 to b5
now the squares defended twice in the
previous position whenever Queen b3
happens the b5 square doesn't have
enough defense so that's why that's
that's one reason to play sex another
potential reason is when when b7 is hit
there are lines where we can put
rook on a7 which looks like a silly
square but if you think about it if the
queen is tying the rook down right to
the b7 square and like the rook can't
move because the Queen is there but you
need to keep your Queen there to keep
the rook on a7 then you've kind of like
won this exchange because the Queen is
worth more than a rook so the queen is
making a lesser piece defend the pawn
the mainlines here
well the main line here is I believe III
and the second main line is c5 again
against all moves like you're the goal
for black is to get his Bishop outside
of the pawn chain play e6 and try to
remain solid so let's let's just start
looking at games so the first game is
between kramnik and Shroff two
world-class players Knight of three on
move one D 5 D 4 C 6 C 4 so we are
reaching our starting position with a
six kramnik decides to play c5 this is
like the move that says you know your
opening is bad I want to punish wait
what you're doing like a six week and
the b6 square
I want to gain space and crush you right
so this is what White's trying to do
sheriff just plays Bishop f5 here which
is the best move you want to get your
bishop outside of the pawn chain and
then close close with e6 Queen b3 and
now an interesting move rook to a7
so the rook looks really silly on a saw
but as I said before if if the queen is
tying down the rook to the b7 square
since the Queen is worth more than a
rook right it's not so important because
if your queen is required to stay on the
B file which where it's not like that
useful like the only reason why the
Queen would be on the beef file is to
attack b7 you have and you have a rook
on a7 I have my queen is free to free to
do whatever it likes so she can go all
across the board to different different
areas and cause a lot of havoc while
this Queen is kind of and this rook is
just taking care of the only problem
this Queen is posing to it
so what black is kind of won this
exchange of moves at least that's blacks
claim
Bishop f4 was played now potentially the
night MBA could be hanging in many lines
so black just played Knight B to d7 h3
white makes lifts for his Bishop because
in some lines black would be chasing
their way so for example if white were
to play e3 the knight h5 would be
something to consider or you could just
pick up this Bishop on f4 h3 and black
does the same with h6 so both sides want
to keep their Bishop e3 and now black
black decides to become extremely
aggressive with the move g5 which is a
very which is a very strong move now in
this position if black were to play e6
right now you might notice over here
this is this is what you do when you're
like studying any opening you should go
to some chess site and look at the
opening database you might see that
white scores really well and high-level
game so these these are all the games
from players above 2200 feet I and in in
this position if white plays Bishop b2
he almost never loses
42% draws and 50% once it's a it's a
slight edge - it's a slight edge to
white and the computer says this is like
point 6 and it's really hard to play
black in this exact position because
white will eventually move this Queen
he'll play b4 he'll play a4 and you'll
play for b5 and blacks plan if you do
nothing I mean is is to trade off this
Bishop on f4 maybe put his knight on on
e4 and and just kind of and just kind of
sit what just solid like you can draw a
lot of games like good players have
drawn here but
yes that that that is what you what
black wants to do unfortunately in this
type of position it's really hard to
achieve because the bishops on f4 right
yeah so blacks blacks eventual plan
pointed out by Claudio is in this this
position to play for rook like let's say
rook c1 and you play rook e8 everybody
played rook e8 and then like Bishop f6
and you're going for a five and this
type of thing is also like solid so it's
just hard to achieve but yeah the
computer is calmed down so yeah you can
this is also a solid approach so g5
isn't like necessary but but it's
interesting it's sheriff is a very
aggressive player and he wanted to win
this game with the black pieces Bishop
h2 Bishop g7 I will say that um the
downside to playing g5 is potentially
the side of the board like pawns cannot
move backwards so all of the black skin
side pawns are going to be weak for the
rest of the game but the advantage to
having this pawn here is you have that
additional space on the Kings side you
can maybe retreat your Bishop to g6 and
your Bishop can go to g7 and you've won
a tempo so black it's black to play and
he's not that he's not behind in
development anymore in fact he has a
slight slight plus and development after
Bishop g7 because it takes me one move
to Castle and it takes you - whoops - so
95 was played or I'm sorry well I can
also Castle queenside happens anyway 95
castles
f3 95 so black needs to get his King to
safety
the castles is mandatory you can't have
your Cain stay in the center forever f3
is played to try to maybe achieve efore
but this is a really double-edged plan
because when white achieves efore his d4
pawn becomes extremely weak and this is
something that black can later target
black and also also f3 is very strange
because if white tries to play Bishop e2
and castles like for example 95 Bishop
e5 black has less space so you want to
trade pieces
that's why 97 was played too but let's
let's pretend black plays like Queen d7
go should be too and then like let's
work a8 right so we've we've moved we're
protecting the pawn with the Queen and
we moved our rook away so maybe you can
do other things but let's say white
castles King side now that f3 has been
played black can potentially think about
Bishop h3 sacrifices and trying to play
on the light squares with maybe Knight
h5 at some point like Bishop e6 Knight
h5 overall f3 is just weakened white
skin side a lot and the only benefit to
doing this would be to play you for but
e 4 also has its minuses namely being
the weakening of the d4 pawn but there's
a better plan for black and that's to
trade off these these pieces the one
pair of knights and the bishop because
it's really hard like black you can't
really pick better squares for blacks
pieces right in this type of position if
you were to pick up a knight right like
you can you can pick up this d7 Knight
put it on any square you want that
obviously you can't capture something
right you will not find a good Square
for it right like it was the knight on
b5 good no I just play a 4 right is the
night on h5 good not really right
like you're you're exposing yourself to
g4 so since this Knight doesn't really
have a future in the position it's
better just to trade it off for your
opponent's night which is why usually in
this variation white white makes an
effort not to play 95 and the best move
here is Bishop e2 but anyway 95 castles
f3 which is bad takes takes 97 Bishop g7
now 97 is a little bit controversial
because on the one hand you're trading
off the bishop which protects your cane
because the bishops basically acting as
as an aggressor on this diagonal
and a defender but on the other hand 97
makes it easier to achieve eise evany 5
and white has weakened his dark squares
so usually when your opponent wheat has
weakened one color complex you want to
trade off the bishop of that same set
color complex happens to be the dark
source takes takes e4 takes takes bishop
g6 so now that white has achieved e4
he's gonna hope to progress in the
center with his pawns
maybe Castle queenside and play h4 and
black is going to try to target the d4
pawn castles Queen side and E 754 to
advance then you could take on c5 with
the tempo on Queen so Queen c4 Queen f6
takes takes and here we can already say
black has a very pleasant advantage he
has the safer Cain because why he he's
pushed his pawns but he's still but the
G pawn is still like within sight is
protected by it
by the H upon the bishop is is is both
attacking and defending the knight on c3
defense for white skin but he's also
behind in development the bishop on f1
does absolutely nothing the rook on h1
doesn't do anything at all the rook on a
7 is bad but that can be changed very
quickly and black has better control of
the dark squares and white virtually has
no no dark script control at all so
already here black has achieved success
in the opening but this game is I mean
sheriff this game is very nice so queen
d4 it's we can see how sheriff finished
off or played the this type of position
so rook rook a queen e3 you bring your
rook your bad rook to the open file
the Queen had Samuel because I was
attacked or sorry I well because it was
about to be attack so this is just
getting out of the way Bishop e2 Queen
e7 targeting the c5 pawn black doesn't
really have like a real weakness that
way can target so and white does white
White's pawn on c5 is sticking out like
a sore thumb and yeah this position is
very bad like it's black black already
yeah it's playing for the advantage I at
top level this is already like it a to
result game 97 hitting c5 okay back so
you repeat and now finally you improve
the Queen to e5 on a central square
Bishop f3 h 5 h 5 by the way is played
um to deter well eath you can think
about g4 sometimes because it one's a
pawn on e4 so like if white does
something stupid like can you be one
then take take Bishop Bishop e2 like
Knight c3 is very good for for black but
so you can think about things like g4
and also after white plays G for himself
you can think about just closing in the
position down with with h5 or taking and
putting the rook on the H file hitting
the g4 pot where does all sorts of
weaknesses a3 just trying to defend the
weakness on c5 also maybe giving love to
the king rook rook e8 take take the ship
d1 um it's not good to it's not good to
trade another pair of Brooks because c5
is going to be so weak and the e4 and E
4 is going to be gone so like in this
type of position like with rooks all all
the works being traded like ephors just
hanging and yeah this position is just
completely waiting for black so rook
t-38 bishop d1 rook d4
Bishop's you to all of blacks pieces are
as active as they can be the rooks on d4
the queens on e5 the Knights pressuring
the e4 pawn and all of whites pieces are
defending one point so something has got
to collapse and black just took the c5
pawn there is nothing I could do you
could take it here but it's better it's
better to take it with the rook because
guai even truth queens all the flax
pieces are better than white so you
don't need to trade them anymore Queen D
it was played 94 and white resigned here
because he's down too many pawns
so yeah black won this game so what can
we take away from this when when white
plays c5 and just tries to kill you with
Queen b3 firstly you can play rook a7
and just defend your b7 weakness then
when they try to stop your plan with a 7
to e5 with Bishop f4 because that's why
you white puts this Bishop on f4 because
blacks long-term plan is to play for a
75 which he did in this game as well
okay both sides just make their most
natural most h3 h h6 here black already
has an interesting decision to make do
you want to play with more space on the
Kings side maybe a slightly weaker King
but you know you have you have good
attacking prospects in the future on
both the Kings side and playing for 75
or do you want to be more solid with
east 6 & e6 Bishop e7 castles putting
your knight on you for putting your
Bishop on our sex and playing for e5
like this one both both clans are good I
slightly prefer the plan with with g5
just because it's a little bit more
combative but both both are totally
playable let's move on to the next game
so we return back to our starting
position with a 6 and how many of you
know the Catalan opening Claudio knows
but you know
all right so the Catalan is one of the
most annoying openings in chess when I
was maybe an expert I I really struggled
against it like every single game where
my opponent play opponent played g3 here
not not in this position but let's say
the e6 Knight f3 I used to play this
with black g3 not through this move
order but through a different a
different move order we would get to
this position I would just like cry like
I lose every single game it was it was
ridiculous you would you just get
positionally ground down and I mean it
just felt like why it had everything to
play for and like like I mean that isn't
true like Black has several good
defenses against the Catalan but oh yeah
Wesley so Wesley so also knows the
Catalan he's one of the world's leading
experts on the opening yeah and the
catalinus - Mario Roper um g3 so here
this was what like the main thing to
deter me from playing the a6 law for a
very long time
this g3 move because it felt to me like
white was getting a very good version of
things that were already known to be
good for him if you were playing
something like dc4 because you you would
just play this type of position where
you're up a pawn but white has lots of
compensation like if you play like e6000
well actually e6 it's not what black
wants to do it probably be five castles
and like a six and yeah blacks up a pawn
but it'sit's really annoying you have to
deal with central pressure pressure on
the queenside sometimes like these
positions where white just plays like b3
takes and queen takes like these
positions are really annoying
I mean you it's true black has an extra
pawn but look look at where all the
blacks pieces are right there on the
back rank and all of whites pieces are
active so when I was trying to come up
four lines in this opening right because
I've played this a number of times on
line and over the board with with the
black pieces I was like well what do I
do against g3 right I really don't want
to take
on c4 and actually there's a very decent
move an alternative which is b5 which
practically forces one of two options
one being b3 and the other being c5
because if black were to do the same
thing with like Bishop g2 then this time
I can take on c4 with my beep on and
instead of white having this huge
pressure on the diagonal I have a pawn
on d5 supported by the pawn on d6 so I
have the strong point on d5 that why it
won't ever be able to crack not to
mention I can also probably ignore it by
just moving my bishop out if if I saw if
I so chose but here beat aces is good
for black so so in this position after
g3 I will recommend the move b5 I feel
like this is a very solid option if if
your opponents play c5 which this is a
game between quartz joins sheriff you
can play g6 switching switching gears
from the last from the last opening or
sorry the last variation where we
immediately play Bishop f5 which i think
is also is also fine here you can also
play like Bishop f5 and and East 6 and
just develop this way black kind of has
like an improved Grune felled where c v
g6 his eventual plan is to play for a 75
and if white plays for e to e4
then he weakens the d4 pawn as you know
a result of having the pawn moved from
from c2 to c4 right because pawns can't
go backwards from c4 can't go to c3 so
d4 if you remove the e pawn from the
board will always be subject to attack
so blacks long-term plan will be to play
for eg 75 take on d4 and play against
either the c5 weakness or if white
recaptures with a pawn play for the d4
weakness and that's that's kind of what
and the bishop on g7 obviously supports
that plan so g6 Bishop g2 Bishop g7
white plays Knight e5 he wants
to prevent this plan forever because if
black achieves e75 then he'll just be
better right so he wants to stop that
from being the case so he puts his
knight on e5 and he's probably going to
try to play F for later and support it
so castles castles Bishop e6 now the
bishop it might surprise you that the
bishop goes to e6 but there but it
supports the d5 pawn it's true it's it's
out of the way the other piece is it
doesn't look so like intimidating right
like it's it's kind of stuck behind
these pawns but it's also looking to
trade itself off maybe for that the
bishop on on g2 which is why the next
move is played like if you were white
here and you played like Bishop e3 or
something Bishop f4 Bishop c5 something
random then black will play queen c8 and
black has a huge positional threat of
playing like Bishop h3 and trading off
his bad Bishop for a White's good Bishop
like rook e1 Bishop h3 and already here
my bishop doesn't look so stupid like
the Kings cut off and I'd rather be
black so that's why h3 is played because
now after Queens see it's true it
attacks the H bond for a second but you
can prevent the bishop from coming in
with g4 anyway what would what would you
guys do here with black how would you
proceed
YH v
I'm going to take the G for point all
right right so you want to undermine the
structure right that's correct so you
want to play h5 and force some kind of
concession so if the pawn moves to g5
then what happens like what are you
going to do
very strong live here the night is a
little bit misplaced on h7 right like it
doesn't it can't come back into the game
very easily right so 97 is correct so
we're attacking the night and if the
knight moves right we can start opening
up the position with f6 and white is
gonna regret all the decisions that he
just made potentially yeah you you can't
keep the knight on e5 because if you
like defend it with f4 and this just
one's a pawn takes takes and takes and
Black has more pawns and is therefore
better I'm gonna bet on the guy with him
cause so h5f three is a huge concession
because the bishop is now blocked in and
well tactics immediately start to happen
so night night reroutes itself to h7 and
this in this variation is slightly
better because g5 cannot be played the H
pawn would be hanging after takes us
there I mean there's so much pressure
like black black is threatening just to
go like 97 and remove the night from the
e5 square he's also trying to play for
f5 if he can open up the Kings side then
he he'll just won because of all these
weaknesses here so it takes takes but
like this is already a huge opening
success for black just because like the
bishop on g2 is is blocked in the bishop
on c1 is on the first rank black is
about to go 97 he has the better
structure the pollen f3 doesn't make any
sense
White's only plans to play for e2 e4 and
when you do that d4 becomes a week
so therefore black is but is better KH 2
is played to prevent Bishop h3 9797
Queen d7 rooks u 1y is getting on the G
while
the king went to hae three or g8f four
and I'm gonna stop here because it's
very clear that after f4 white has made
a whole bunch of lights core weaknesses
so bishop the bishop can go to f5 and
then I can go to f6 and this is this is
already positionally very very bad for
for white this is strategically lost so
yeah I'm gonna stop here I will link
people to the study if you want to
continue studying this game that I I
will I highly encourage that yes
the court should I sure off alright now
the next game is very high level and it
deals with the main line like in the
main line of main lines which is in our
starting position cool actually
a different move order you play to e3
which is something that that I actually
I've done a number of times the point is
in some lines you can put the knight on
you to but against a6 the knight doesn't
belong in 82 so you should put it put it
on f3 black black in this game play
Bishop f5 now for some context the main
move is to play b7 b 5 which is also
fine b3 and then Bishop g4 and this
position is very solid
you got your bishop outside of the pawn
chain you're ready to go east 697 maybe
Bishop to d6 or e7 or before potentially
depending upon the situation in here and
your castling and and have absolutely no
problems and white can do very little to
disturb that but in this game Carlsen
just decided to play Bishop f5 after
Bishop b2 play h6 and and he says well I
don't really need to advance my pawn to
b5 yet it's not it's not really an issue
because after Queen b3 I can just go
Roque sabot which is the other plan in
this position for black take sticks and
okay oops
all of these all of these moves are
natural take 6 so
why does trying to claim that in the
exchange Slav the wreck doesn't belong
on a seven which is true but the problem
is that in the exchange Slav right since
the night hasn't moved from from b8
black black is totally fine because he
can put his night mc6 in general the
only way white has an advantage in the
exchange Slav is if black plays ninety
seven too early so for example Bishop d2
97 oops d5 is even hanging here but like
let's pretend the d5 isn't hanging like
this type of position
we're like white castles and e6 this is
a slight advantage because the nice
better on c3 than d7 even this isn't
like so bad like this isn't the end of
the world but White has has a pleasant
plus here because the knight would
really rather be on c6 after take after
taking on on d5 then the knight will
make its way to the c6 square 9 ft 7
takes takes notice he took with the
Queen because he wants this night to go
to c6 so 9a 496 Queen b6 rook f8
defending its colleague on the a7 square
95 Queen c8 black is rather passive at
the moment but it's like Jacob Wilkins
always used to say like if blacks
positions like a coiled spring it's
ready to jump back into life a3 Bishop
d6 and Bishop c7 kicking the White Queen
out Queen goes to e8 or it goes back to
be 8 and all the blacks pieces are
starting to make sense again so yeah it
takes takes takes takes takes so white
white and thinks he's won a pawn but b2
is hanging so that's the the tactical
justification there should be one this
should be 7 takes and once again you
sidestep this because you have threats
on the back rank with rook be one quark
c6 and this game was declared a draw
after or they agree to a draw after it
be one because both players are around
2800 and they they know how this
position is very very
equal so I mean all the pawns are on one
side if white plays well in this opening
then you know like he'll draw but
drawing isn't the worst thing in the
world with black so this was I think the
highest level human game that I have in
here the next game is between Peter
Svidler and and Mala Mala cough but I
want to first talk about other
variations so if Y plays a four which is
another side line then I would recommend
the move Bishop f5 Queen b3 and then row
k7 and like the other lines if your if
your opponent goes Bishop f4 should play
e6 III and go a5 with the idea of
putting the knight to the be for square
or the bishop to the be for square and
already here like black black has very
few problems this position is very solid
and development is kind of easy like the
plans the plans are very smooth it
doesn't take it doesn't take a lot to
understand though there should be seven
ninety five castles Bishop d3 trade off
your bad Bishop four White's good Bishop
because your pawns are on light squares
black and blacks are on sorry whites are
on dark squares blacks are on light
squares ninety seven Queen b6 and this
this type of position is very is very
solid and around equal so this is this
is equality and that's that's like one
of the side lines I had a game here
actually a blitz game I don't have this
this game on file the only game where I
ever beat been Feingold in a rated game
Grandmaster Ben Feingold was in the a6
love he played a four and I played
Bishop f5 he played Bishop but I don't
think I don't remember if you play
Bishop f4 or not I think he played c5 or
something and anyway I actually won that
game so I have pleasant memories here
but I would recommend playing Bishop f5
and work a7 and this in this in this
line other things the white can do does
anybody have any suggestions like what
what would you like to do with the white
pieces like this is the open and I'm
proposing you can try to refute it
right now this is your opportunity
I'm Bishop g5 is an interesting
variation but here black can go b5 if
you so you have to you have to do
something with this pawn right now
normally in these variations black is
playing Bishop like b4 right so like b3
like so when the bishop has gone to g5
white has to be very very careful that
something bad doesn't happen like a 6
and Bishop b4 and like Queen I 5 so for
example you see 6 here right which may
not be the best move if I were to pull
the play careless move like III you
could already be in a lot of trouble
because of Queen a5 and if you play Rick
c1 the night Ecore and there's an attack
on g5 and c3
if you defend c3 you might not even care
about g5 just playing Bishop before and
white loses material so white has to be
a little bit careful about just moving
his his Bishop out when black has this
idea of playing b5 yeah for some context
or ship g5 v 5 and here here white
should take on d5 twice play e3 and
white scores
Oh white scores really well but it kind
of calms down after black plays into
this position and this is this is really
salt really solid blacks eventually
going to play 494 the bishop is a little
bad on b7 but the the thing you have in
exchange for the for the bad bit bumpy 7
is you can be you're potentially already
playing for the C 4 square so if a night
arrives on the c-4 square then I mean
it's a good night and if it's traded off
then your bishop doesn't look so stupid
anymore so this is this is also my
recommended line taking on d5 plane you
should play a 6 Bishop d3 and Bishop e7
let's see what else
what else is there so the problem with
with from whites point of view is all of
the all of the main lines are kind of
like them I mean there aren't so many
logical moves if in like the normal Slav
like let's pull it let's say like in
this position white has or like a back a
few moves White has a few moves like he
hasn't moved Queen c2 he has the move
like like g3 even III with Knight d2
like he has he has options after 93 a6
in this position his his only options
are somehow to respond to the idea of B
7 B 5 because if black can play that
move potentially he can even just stand
better like after g3 b5 I don't think
black has any problems whatsoever
like I'd already rather be black which
is weird because I had a really hard
time against the Catalan when I was a
very active tournament player but anyway
I guess let's continue on with with
fiddler and Malikov because nobody has
decided to refute this opening c4 c6 93
Knight f6 Knight of 3a6
III so we're in the main line main line
of the main lines b5 and it's Fiddler
here plays c5 which i think is a little
bit dubious because it's releasing the
tension the best move here is b3 and and
then black can play either Bishop f5 and
or a ship g4 g6 Bishop d3 Bishop g4 h3
take sticks so white as the bishop pair
but black has put all of his pawns on
the light squares right including g6 h7
the only one that isn't on a light score
yet is the ESO and pawn where it's
reserving its right to move and you know
two squares at once to e5 immediately so
it hasn't moved yet but even though I've
given up the bishop pair it isn't really
felt because I have no dart like I
all of my pawns on the light squares and
my bishop would it would have been bad
anyway so I just decided to trade off
now usually in these type of positions
I would rather trade the LightSquared
bishop for the for the light square
bishop because that's just I mean I like
bishops that much now this is a move
that nobody would play other than me but
this is also interesting playing Bishop
f5 now this structure is a little bit
bad I mean I like it I think I'm the
only only person in the world who likes
the structure for black but the point
the point is you have you have the G
file to work with you can play e6 97
Bishop g7 maybe like King King over to
h8 put your work on g8 black has a lot
of pluses here too so like Bishop f5 is
also interesting but in the game Bishop
g4 was played h3 Bishop f3 takes Bishop
g7 g4 and black plays e5 so there's this
rule right like when your opponent plays
on the win you respond in the center and
that's exactly what black has done so
Queen g3 why why is this potentially not
good
what should black play which Knight ft7
correct and well why why is this good
for black
all right well highest highest rated
player the audience eyes to him assume I
don't know maybe it says that it just
looks good for black
so I greet agree with that assessment
yeah sent essential Quan c5 is a week
it's hard to defend c5 because c3 is
handy so yeah this is just good for
black it's a night ft 7 so Queen g3
potentially threatening to take although
even that like even pass like does white
have a threat yeah boy sorry I'm dumb
Queen Queen Queen takes e5 with check
but in this position we can respond to
it with black so 9 ft 7 anyway just
defending any five putting pressure on
the c5 and opening up our beautiful
bishop on g7 92 defend 84 27 both
protecting the e5 pawn and attacking the
c5 pawn castles h5 f3 Knight of fate a 4
and B 4 a 5 here white is actually
achieved like kind of a lot right like
the fact that the pawns are on a 5 and B
4 aren't like if I had everything I
wanted that like black black would never
have the pawns on 85 and before this is
this is an achievement for white but on
the other hand black has also achieved a
lot he's achieved a 75 which is really
hard to do in this opening of whites
like really trying to prevent it and all
of my pieces are gonna find good squirts
like mine I can go to d7 when I can go
to e6 and like White's position has
already reached kind of its maximum
maximum potential like if I put my work
on u1i I can't think of any better
squares for whites pieces which is a
real problem because in chess you need
plans right you need long-term plans
otherwise like playing a position
without a plan it's all I I don't want
to say like it's better to play with a
bad plan rather than no plan at all but
I I'm not entirely sure what White's
going to be doing here because if you
play off for f4
then you're definitely worse after
you've four and white black can play for
f5 if you play e for yourself with white
and you try to open the position up with
your two bishops you have to be very
careful the d4 doesn't just hang so
after E 5 white white plays white has to
play e4 because if you don't do this now
then you're just gonna be a much worse
after black plays e for himself
so take stakes and black put his night
on the best square which is e6
rook e1 h for queen f2 castles blacks is
going to be playing on the dark squares
and already here black is her choice
because of his weakened King side f4
takes d4 c5 is no weak and black has one
set of central pawn to zero so that's
that's already something that he can be
playing for f5 95 it should be 1 this
game finished really fast because but
black is completely winning d3 91 I mean
look where White's pieces are they're
not doing anything at all this isn't
discovered attack but with a very little
very little poison to it
Queen d6 Bishop e2 Bishop d4 Bishop e3
94 Queen h4 g5 so we've distracted the
Queen away from they eat the e3 Bishop
after Queen h4 g5 we the picture
obviously can't take on g5 because of
the rules of chess and if the Queen
moves away somewhere gets 5 then now now
that the queen is no longer on the f2
square right we can just play D 2 D 3 D
2 g 5 just make sure that the Queen
can't get back into the game g3 f6
White's playing for Queen g6 in Queen g7
so if you fall asleep then you you'll
lose the game Queen f6 and here Bishop
d4 always played Queen d4 Kim G 2 and
here
oops actually white white might get away
with like a draw if you let them even
though you can come back with Queen g7
so it's better just to take on d1 and
make a night then to then to make a
queen because it's check and this is a
really nice finish and actually it's an
appropriate and appropriate time to
resign because black has three nights
and them on the board which is extremely
rare anyway so also possible in this
variation with III is to play the main
line with b5 and Bishop g4 and played
this type of position if Queen takes and
you can play e5 this is also an
interesting approach I if you're
interested in its this is a game between
so in niqua there's also this game where
white plays a four where I can show my
recommended line okay seven Bishop f4 e
six and a five against a four
you don't so if I were to play C five
like here right
you play Bishop f5 and they go Queen b3
Rock a seven since we know or rather
since we don't know that b4 is gonna be
weak we can assume the whites not going
to voluntarily we can that Square and
your Knights not going to be good on on
before so it's better just to move it to
d7 but against a four we we now have a
potential square to play for right so we
we don't need to move the knight from b8
yet because it's not clear where the
best square is yet so Bishop f5 rook a
seven that's why in this position sefa
III a5 black is playing for this instead
of just moving his Knight to d7 Bishop
e2 h6 castles 97 anyway you can also
think about putting it on a6 and before
in this game he decided just to put it
on D side
but also I think 96 is totally fine here
yes fine so 96 is also a good move I
actually think it's better than 90 so
potential improvement h3p should be 792
why was 92 played in this position what
was blacks idea
what could black have played in this so
if if white played some random move like
this
what could black do potentially or let's
let's make two more moves castles and
Rick doing black is already totally fine
g5 that's really committal but it's it's
this is an interesting decision you
could you could do this with the point
that you're like going Kenji Kenji seven
and like plane on the side yeah that's
possible but um yeah that's very
aggressive
I think Sheriff what it would approve
but there's there's something like a
little bit more solid eight that there
like black starting the reason why that
is like g5 doesn't have anything to do
with ninety two great like ninety two
doesn't prevent g5 so you want to make
this move an g5 potentially
yeah oh wait what Knight h5
yeah after Knight h5 what just goes
Bishop h2 right what's your knight doing
on h5 yeah g4 so threat you have to be
careful yeah yeah 94 and the point is
you want to trade off your this night
right and you want to put your other
night to you for and all of your pieces
make sense once again so black can play
for this and also now g5 is is more
threatening this is a potential plan see
ya in this game that's why white play 92
castles Bishop f3 Queen b6 takes takes C
597 and now blacks plan is I should be
obviously everybody in the class by now
what is blacks plan everybody except for
Claudia who knows everything
what is blacks plan what is black
playing for
sorry a ship D to the night some dudes
alright d3 you mean yeah okay
d3 yeah but okay if you put your Bishop
on d3 right like let's say pass right
ship d3 and I put my rook on you one or
something like what is your Bishop d1 d3
the it was not doing 105 I'm not sure I
I mean I'm not saying it's wrong but
what like what's the idea I think Bishop
d3 is maybe a little early like when you
when you play these moves you you that
you have to make sure that they're like
winning like ken h1 was really stupid
because maybe even 94 is like possible
again but um let's say I play a better
stupid move like work c1 Bishop Bishop
d3 Erick do one right your Bishop isn't
better on this diagonal because it's
shut out of the game right so there's no
reason to have it move to D 3 words
unprotected where it is protected on a5
right because potentially there could be
some tactics involving the loose bishop
on d3 but I I guarantee you that there
will be no tactics happening to the
bishop on f5 coming from like a minor
piece like the worst case scenario like
I trade this night for the bishop it's
like okay I take with that bomb so like
nothing like fancy will happen but after
Bishop d3 potentially you could I don't
know lose area upon denied b3 like
attempt like discovery something like
future things like Bishop d3 is not a
bad move it's just something that I
wouldn't do because I could blunder
later c5 yeah sorry so blacks plan in
this position is to play east six to e5
that's what blacks playing for and he
wants to play against the weakness on d4
after E for I believe I'm not sure this
this person is rated 24.95 he's pretty
strong his opponents much of all like
stronger 2570 that's another level
he plays he plays III III - II for now
now already weakening the d4 pawn so
black didn't even need to play for this
e six to e5 to weaken the d4 pawn boy
just voluntarily weakens it but on the
other hand white has achieved more space
he's also given up the d5 square so
black trades everything because he's
down down in space you you can give away
the bishop pair because the knight on d5
is is worth the bishop the knight is
better than both bishops on d5 so
probably white will have to trade his
bishop for them for the night eventually
one of his Fisher's for the night so
rook d7 and black is going to put all of
his pieces at 93 notice if you play this
move that like your work is going to get
trapped somehow so I can like come back
and attack d4 so I'm black is putting
all of his pieces to target the d4
pulling so and I go back to this before
rook goes to d8 and black puts all his
pawns on light squares he has a dark
square bishop and now having completed
his plan he is now targeting the d4 pawn
with all of his pieces rook to 254 why
does this work so why can't white just
take everything on d4 does black have a
tactic here
you know block them off
check boy yes correct
and this is a fork you can also take
this once more and then do do it again
depending upon which ending you want to
play but both are good so white white
dropped the d4 pawn due to some tactics
also he was gonna drop it anyway like
you this is not like a permanent
situation like it's probably just gonna
win win the pawn eventually so yeah rook
d2 black was just in time took took on
d4 takes white sprain for some opposite
color Bishop ending but this this type
of position is usually winning for black
because this is weak all the whites
pawns are on dark squares so my bishop
will eventually be able to target them
like if my bishop ever gets the e1 then
I just take all of the Kings side pawns
so the King can't run too far away he
always has to stay around the Kings side
and black insert plane for the a file
but he needs to defend his bishop on d4
so e5 and now he has a keen side
majority so he can also start pushing
those pawns but first he forces white to
push b2 to b3
Rickey 764 Bishop c3 36 work back to e8
and now that he's forced forced white to
let blacks Bishop be good on c3 he's
going to start advancing his majority so
before just improve the King and now we
push our pawns and this position is
completely when your for black because
he has more pieces if you want to study
this game in more detail I
I will obviously link the study later
but this is a team oaken and Volkov with
the black pieces now the last two games
are the same opening and it isn't really
like a part of I've talked about because
this isn't like a specific opening right
like it's more of like a complex in in
every system for black so like against
most moves you have a um
number of ideas but first you want to
play a six if your opponent puts your
knight on D - or or anywhere else it
doesn't matter you play a six III and
you put your bishop outside of the pawn
chain f5g for whatever your preference
is you know like whatever and you play e
six or something and you get this type
of position it's very solid you get to
play like 4b 597 put your Bishop on d6
or 87 and just the the ideas for black
are to eventually play for a 75 or
potentially to play for h6 and g5 there
there are lots of ideas for for black in
this and this opening the last two games
aren't like real games because they
aren't between humans however these are
super computer games these games happen
today these are better than the best
humans have ever played ever they're
running on like a you know like a I
don't know like a 40 core computer
somewhere and they they took all day to
come up with this game and well they
played this type of opening a6 Bishop d3
Bishop g4 and both games ended in a draw
which is a very good sign because it
means that the opening for black was you
know like sound so it's been tested at
the highest level if any of you would
like to to try this with the black
pieces I would be very very happy thank
you that's all I have for you
[Music]
you
[Music]